but we begin with a dramatic development
and the legal drama surrounding former
president Donald Trump but it's not
about the charges he's facing here in
New York former vice president Mike
Pence says he's now willing to testify
to a D.C grand jury about Trump's
attempts to overturn the 2020 election
it's all part of the special counsel's
investigation into the events of January
6th you'll remember rioters chanted hang
Mike Pence at the Capitol after the
former president lied to support us
about Pence's ability to stop the
certification of the election Robert
Costas following this in Washington Bob
good morning good morning Nate this
federal investigation of January 6 could
be the most robust case facing Trump and
now as former vice president is willing
within certain bounds to testify about
possible illegal acts he might have
witnessed as the special counsel ramps
up this probe of the former president
and others
I obviously have nothing to hide an
advisor to former vice president Mike
Penn says he could testify before the
D.C Federal grand jury within weeks I
think the American people deserve the
whole story possibly providing a vivid
first-hand account of then president
Donald Trump's attempts to stay in
office this is an earthquake former
Federal prosecutor Scott Fredrickson
said Pence could play a key role in
special counsel Jack Smith's
investigation into Trump's actions what
did he say to the vice president
there may not be a more critical witness
for the special counsel than the vice
president himself fans could reveal
details about his Oval Office meetings
with Trump just days before January 6.
and if the pressure plan that involved
tossing out electors could amount to a
criminal conspiracy to overturn the 2020
election it comes after a judge ruled
that several of Trump's former top aides
must testify including former Chief of
Staff Mark Meadows the decision came
hours after Trump pleaded not guilty to
34 felony counts of falsifying business
records in a New York hush money case
Tuesday night Trump railed against the
special counsel in the doj probe this
lunatic special prosecutor named Jack
Smith the same special counsel
investigating his handling of classified
records the boxes hoax you know the
boxes hoax that investigation of
classified materials has some Trump
allies increasingly on edge sources tell
CBS news that many staffers at
Mar-A-Lago and Trump aides have
testified about whether Trump obstructed
the government's efforts to secure the
documents Natalie
all right Bob thank you so much